revoir c'est à dire eric dupond-moretti
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
ben non c'est vrai que c'est le fantasme
un peu de toutes les boites de prod
française d'avoir des politiques dans
les émissions ce quelqu'un aux états
unis avaient un conseiller de la maison
blanche qui a fait danser avec les stars
moi j'ai une petite info non mais c'est
vrai mais si oui c'est vrai la singer
ils ont voulu avoir
eric dupond-moretti reste à savoir si
c'était avant qu'il soit nommé ministre
ou pas d'accord c'est vrai que ça fait
un peut fantasmer tout le monde et j'ai
une petite info sur un politique
la production danse avec les stars a
approché jean lassalle non gens-là ça
lui va dire oui jean lassalle jean
lassalle jours la salle de danse dans
les bars et danser dans une vidéo
c'était marrant ça avait fait le buzz à
l'époque ils rêvent d'avoir un politique
mais c'est pas j'adore ça j'achète à ça
franchement ya bien eu des vues de
budget qui était secrétaire d'état et
qui a fait de marseille eric dupond
moretti dans ma single non non je ne
vois pas mais il sera dans la chanson
secrète une famille gérard darmon
émiratis valérie bénaïm moi je trouve
que c'est de ce mélange des genres il et
il est vraiment très hasardeux moi
j'aime bien le hasard de ces hasards de
quintaux le coup on mélange évidemment
des chanteurs et éventuellement des
politiques pourquoi pas mais là c'est du
pur divertissement
ce n'est pas comme aux états unis où la
politique là-bas est un vrai spectacle
oui savent se mettre en scène où ils
font carrément même des sketches
moi aujourd'hui je trouve que c'est
assez choquant ou ce voyage n'aurait
c'qui une récession actuelle dans
laquelle on se trouve
il ya beaucoup de problèmes à régler oui
ils ont d'autres choses à faire quand il
se retrouvait sa place en séries pour
faire je pense que il l'aurait pas fait
eric dupont qui maintient le porte
parole du gouvernement après on aura du
mal à ça je rappelle que patrick
sébastien à l'époque il avait reçu
jacques chirac qui avait chanté c'est
ainsi que le bien des choses pas en un
tas d'hommes politiques qui s'est pas
très dévalorisant web apps à l'époque
était un peu plus apaisé
alors bien sûr garde hier instaurera la
coke qui comme m + pc
non mais on fait plein aujourd'hui que
les gens attaquent directement les
politiques et un moment donné les
politiques il faut qu'il reste aussi à
leur place non pas à les délivrer bien
sûr s'il vous plaît on a et b - tant que
charlotte with à savoir tirer morgane
hockey marleix de charlotte morgan
morgan succéder foutage de gueule obligé
de prendre que des mouvements civils
du coup ils sont complets et sans
rigoler même elle est alors oui morgan
moi je fais du foutage de gueule on est
privé de sortie et une faune le
divertissement moi j'ai pas envie de
rire quand des politiques aujourd'hui
s'occupe pas de nous et du co lead et il
ne faut pas les bonnes choses ne
traînent pas les bonnes mesures nous
prive de sortie le dessert et samuel
basque et masques singer voilà et voile
géante à l'encontre des raisons d'être
contre pékin un message vidéo voit juste
moretti pour ce soir dans la chance va
voir on va voir d'abord ce nom dans la
chanson secrète non mais là on parle pas
de ça on parle de ma soeur est approché
par un tigre et eric dupond-moretti il a
jamais dit qu'il est le fait suite et je
pense que c'était même pas dans les
rêves
à bien y regarder il rappelle mosane
masque regardez
les dernières années entre politique et
divertissement la distance s'est fait de
plus en plus fine c'est par exemple le
cas de roselyne bachelot qui est devenue
chroniqueuse télé puis société aux
grosses têtes avant de redevenir
ministre de la culture
une exposition médiatique qui semble
très tentante c'est par exemple le cas
avec eric dupond moretti a tué le garde
des sceaux ministre de la justice qui
s'est retrouvé dans l'émission de tf1 la
chanson secrète qu'il devait à la base
il chantait une chanson pour son ami
gérard darmon l'avocat est entre temps
devenu ministre a donc refusé
l'invitation sur le plateau mais a tout
de même accepté de participer à
l'émission en or ils sont un petit
message pour son amie une séquence qui
en rappelle une autre
lorsque emmanuel macron avait enregistré
une séquence humoristique lors de
l'émission de jean paul rouve sur tmc il
y a quelques semaines dans la vie chacun
fait ce qu'il peut
un mélange des genres qui peut déranger
mais qui est loin d'être à son maximum
le journal le parisien révèle ainsi qu
eric dupond moretti aurait même été
approché pour participer à mastin gher
si la communication est établie entre la
production de l'émission et l'actuel
ministre
son nouveau poste au gouvernement a tout
fait capoter alors les politiques
ont-ils leur place qu'ont les missions
divertissement voilà mes chéris mais bon
je pense que c'était vraiment de
l'utopie comme on dit dans le milieu
voilà des gens qui parle bien français